in early 2019 two brothers reyes and
amir khajii founded africa's first ever
cryptocurrency trading platform powered
by ai
afrocrypt
considering reyes and his brother were
only 20 and 17 at the time designing and
launching something like this was pretty
impressive they opened offices in
johannesburg south africa an
international office in hong kong and
afrika started to look like a massive
success the attraction of afrika was
that any investor could deposit fiat
money or bitcoin and expect up to a 10
return not every year but every single
month
you could literally double your money in
a year who wouldn't want that in its
first two years alone investors poured
3.6 billion dollars into the platform
confident that they were about to profit
big time but then on april 13 2021
something went terribly wrong
amir khajii the ceo of afrocrypts sent
out a letter to investors informing them
that afrikaf and all their clients
wallets have been hacked all the money
had vanished immediately all withdrawals
and other transactions were frozen a
full system audit was underway
obviously investors panicked
they tried calling afrocrypt and even
reached out to the khajii brothers
directly but heard nothing back the
brothers have been wiped off the face of
the earth they didn't answer their
phones they wore at their homes even
their social media accounts had been
deleted when people drove to the africa
office they found an empty lot the
building next door was a carpeting and
flooring business not exactly what you
would expect from a multi-billion dollar
crypto company 3.6 billion dollars in
bitcoin had disappeared and the only two
people who had any idea what was going
on also disappeared
then just a few weeks later the brothers
reached out over the internet they
wouldn't say where they were only that
they fled south africa because they
feared for their lives they denied all
allegations and said that they were more
than happy to cooperate with the
authorities to help figure out what
really happened but there is no way they
were stepping foot back in the country
months before the hack the brothers got
citizenship on the island of vanuatu a
little island with no taxes and
visa-free access to over 130 countries
and since then they've been traced to
tanzania dubai and london but their
current location is still a mystery
this is how two brothers became
billionaires in just two years by
pulling off the biggest crypto heist in
history
[Music]
so
[Music]
reyes and amir khajii weren't new to
crypto when they started afrocrypt in
2019. reyes had apparently got into
mining bitcoin when he was just 13 years
old while still in school he had made a
trading algorithm to let him and his
brother make money while attending
classes real child genius stuff or at
least that's what they claim
according to the brothers their
algorithm has such great returns that
reyes was even flown to china by huby
one of china's crypto platforms
they came from a well-off family so they
didn't look like desperate poor kids
looking for easy money
with such a great backstory it's no
surprise people were pumped to hear that
the brothers were starting an investment
company that they could get in on africa
promised incredible returns and on the
surface it worked for almost two years
every month africa's investors would get
statements on their accounts showing
their balances shooting up and as word
spread about afrocrypt success more and
more people wanted to get in on the
profits but to become a client every new
investor had to sign an agreement
what the brother snuck into that
agreement was a clause that released
africa from any liability specifically
in the case of hacking
[Music]
and as we all know no one reads the
terms of service no one does due
diligence no one wants to know how these
returns were possible all they needed to
hear was that they were going to be
guaranteed money and a lot of it so
business kept booming
for you was installing sprinklers for me
was digging ditches on the construction
crew i never would have started home
depot if i hadn't had that experience
as clients saw their returns go up every
month on paper their number one priority
was getting new clients to join the firm
so they used every trick in the book
they took advantage of their family's
muslim connections to reach out to a
tight-knit wealthy community in south
africa and they flexed they bought a
lamborghini huracan in cash rented out a
mansion spent thousands of dollars on
suits and watches and even booked a
family vacation where the first class
flights set them back at least 35 000
dollars they were living the
stereotypical crypto billionaire
lifestyle and people fell for it hard if
two guys who were barely in their 20s
could be living the good life their
investment company obviously had to work
and you would be a complete idiot not to
invest so people started pouring money
into africans some investors were
already rich others used their life
savings their parents pension funds or
even sell cars to free up enough cash to
invest afrocrypt was going to make the
new generation of millionaires that is
until it all went sideways badly
[Music]
april 13 2021 amir sends out the letter
announcing the hack and the music stops
that letter was their first clue that
something was really wrong it was asking
clients not to go to lawyers and report
the hack to authorities in amir's words
it would only delay the recovery process
end quotes
but instead of getting fooled again
investors went straight to a law firm
who eventually took the matter to the
cops the only problem was the kiji
brothers were already gone no one could
find them or bring them in for
questioning even the afrika website has
suddenly gone offline at first people
were sure finding the money would be
easy because everything is on a
blockchain but that's where something
called tumblers and mixers come in see
when you steal money from people that
money that you got from them whether it
be cash or bank transfers is now dirty
so you need to wash the blood out of
that money you need to make it look like
it came from a legitimate source you
need to launder it traditionally to
launder cash you would just need to
slowly inject it into a cash-heavy
business like a local restaurant casino
or strip club but with something like
bitcoin where every transaction is on a
public ledger it's a little bit more
tricky that's where tumblers and mixers
come in these are basically digital
laundry machines for crypto where a
bunch of people send their dirty crypto
into the pool the algorithm mixes it all
up with a ton of transactions of random
amounts and then it spits out the
original amount you put in in random
increments over time making it very hard
to trace each individual bitcoin back to
the crime and that's what the african
brothers did with their almost 69 000
bitcoins days before fleeing the country
the brothers sold the lambo the ferrari
and the mansion as investigators dug
deeper into the brothers financial and
travel plans things got even crazier
[Music]
over the past 10 months since the
brothers disappeared they've reached out
a few times online every time they do
they deny any involvement in the
disappearance of the money this would
have been a little more believable if
the evidence against them wasn't piling
up as much first it came out that both
brothers have bought citizenship on the
island country of venuatu just a few
months before the heck vanuatu is a tax
haven that offers visa-free access to
over 130 countries then people started
coming forward and saying that another
one of the brothers crypto trading
companies called ray creates had also
been hacked in may 2019 all the bitcoin
had magically disappeared
right around the same time they started
afrocrypt and also seven days before the
afrika tech their staff lost access to
all the company's backend platforms when
a private investigator was hired he
couldn't find any trace of malicious
activity on the africa domain or server
and the brothers promises to help
investigators in south africa well just
a few months after disappearing they
fired their lore and haven't been heard
from since some clues suggest they may
be hiding in tanzania
and for investors health from the
government or law enforcement isn't
really an option the south african
financial sector conduct authority the
organization that's supposed to regulate
investment and trade in the country
can't do anything that's because in
south africa cryptocurrency is a
non-regulated security so their hands
are tied this plus the fact that no one
seems to have any idea where they are
means that they didn't just orchestrate
the biggest crypto heist in history they
may still get away with it as
billionaires in a world where privacy is
non-existent the kajii brothers have
successfully disappeared time will tell
if it stays that way
[Music]
sure there's a lot of sketchy stuff like
this that goes on in the crypto world
just like the early days of the gold
rush in california it was lawless but it
was also ripe with opportunity
you smell that what is that
opportunity
no money
and the hottest niche in crypto right
now is flipping nfts where people are
making life-changing money just from
getting on an nft hype early on buying
and then selling soon after for insane
amounts of money and one way to do it is
to look at what crypto whales are buying
crypto whales are influential people who
have a ton of crypto so if you buy an
nft project others tend to follow
pushing the price up the hard part is
catching on to these crypto whale hype
trains early on so you're not left
holding the bag but what if there was an
algorithm that monitored the wallet of
crypto whales and then alerted you every
single time they bought an nft if you
had such a tool you could get alerted
when a whale buys check out that nft
project they bought buy it yourself if
you want and then sell it for hopefully
a higher price well you're in luck
because that's where project metamux
comes in metamox is a tight-knit
community tailor made for beginners who
are looking to make money in the nft
space but it's not just for beginners
though there is a network of high-level
nft traders and resources to help at all
levels and within their discord they
have this exact whale bot tracker tool
that gives you a discord alert whenever
a whale buys and the best part is that
this discord is 100 free right now with
the link below
the catch is that when their metamux nft
project launches the whalebot and the
other tools and resources in the discord
will only be available to holders of the
nft which has a very low supply of only
four thousand four hundred forty four
mega mugs so you're gonna want to get in
while you can for free there's a ton of
other cool stuff that comes with the
discord and after you get in you'll even
get to sign up for their whitelist
giveaway spot for free where they'll be
giving away a hundred whitelist spots to
be the first in line to mint their
metamox nft which is expected to sell
out fast due to the low supply they plan
to mint this in january
to enter this whitelist giveaway join
the menu mugs discord for free by going
to jake.yt metamucks with the link below
it literally costs zero dollars there's
no risk you literally just have to join
the discord for free the link below will
take you to their twitter where you can
follow them and then join their discord
with the link in their twitter bio again
that's jake.yt metamonks with the link
below and don't worry if you don't win
one of the 100 whitelist spots there
will be more whitelist opportunities as
they get closer to the release thanks to
metamox for sponsoring this video
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you